and I would like to give a shout out to
I think his name was Ken he works at the
sandwich shop near where we used to go
to school he said what's up he's a cool
guy he cooked camka yeah totally Hey oh
wait why don't I get a shout out I have
one I was like I had one I wanted to you
yeah we weren't even saying it
confidently I'm sorry
being guy wants an uncomfortable shout
out as if you don't want to shut him out
well cuz I don't like guys think like I
don't want you out out to this guy
come on man yeah be like Tom Cruise Wow
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls more
Minds Gregory and I'm John we're gonna
go to the next level we're gonna reach
up to the next level there was a joke I
made forever ago
huh ooh I heard they were making a
sequel Jack Reacher oh no it was called
Jack Reacher Jack off reach around I
don't remember what what episode was on
a movie news video that I don't do
anymore
okay so Jack Reacher never go back looks
like the Reacher is going back though
that's that title implies I remember
this movie came out man like everyone
was just bitching about how Tom Cruise
was casting it because he's not like six
foot five and two nor something pounds
it was that like a huge chest I think it
was like blond hair - this is very
opposite from the source material I'm
supposed to look like the guy from The
Venture Brothers yeah I think so like
more like golf laundry Brooks
um however when the movie came out
though people were like you know what
though Tom Cruise he he got the internal
stuff down he wasn't like super good the
whole time you know you can get nasty
you'll kill people and [ __ ] what I felt
kind of like an older school sort of
crime novel sort of yoshino which made
it more interesting he's mysterious and
stuff he's real clearly taken really
seriously like putting a lot of work in
there and and it was also like the film
where we saw Jai Courtney we were like
that's pretty cool
I remember people were like that Jai
Courtney guys got some yeah his next
movie was like good day to die hard yeah
and then it went Verner Hertzog like
there were these weird quirky things
about those like it's kind of cool
now before we watch this trailer I'm
already wondering what direction this is
going to go down I know there's a series
of books but what a lot of people were
surprised by what I noticed is that when
the movie actually came out it wasn't
like out the trailer advertised it was a
murder mystery with a few action scenes
the trailers made it look like it was
going to be like another Mission
Impossible and kind of film in a Mission
Possible meets Jason Bourne like her
love like it's grittier and Christopher
McQuarrie like he launched his like
strong bond with Tom Cruise after the
only organ yeah except in this one
Christopher McQuarrie is not directing
it so I
I don't know acting it I don't know if
it's gonna go down more the action route
did he write it let's find out let's
pull up the m.d. book he did not write
and the director that's right it's the
guy who did the Last Samurai uh he's
done some movies since the last severide
that might not have been right too much
but Thomas Cruise I feel like when he
has faith in the right director he can
do cuz he's pretty much I controlled a
lot of his films like he he decides a
lot of the time who he thinks should
direct on the Contacts I'm personally
often can always kind of count on Tom
Cruise production to be pretty good you
know and Cobie Smulders is in this to
job excited about yeah I'm interested to
see how how that works
might used to hurry movies in bill
happen here just by one guy come all
down with his bare hands nice higher
limit turnaround mister hands slowly are
these cool aggravated assault a felony
in this state mr. Reacher processing in
Denver County
two things are going to happen in the
next 90 seconds excuse me
first iPhone open there's gonna ring
second you're gonna be wearing these
cuffs on your waist prison that is one
magnificent prophecy mr. Reacher
Oh how's it going to do the handcuff
thing just gonna keep on ringing when
ain't going to be see I'm a rebel either
legend folks wonder why you left triple
heart Silver Star there's this big day
the best people say you leave it with
someone's head is creature from agent
Turner major Turner's better arrested or
charged espionage he's incentive now
he'll know almost read you know are they
going oh no anything foolish strong
Vista to the border maybe I rip your arm
off beat you to death with it if you're
a junior my men were shot by one of our
own whoa this is bigger than I imagined
yeah there's anyone on your watch
Reacher
what this movies gone Hollywood so you
should stop running because I'm gonna
start hunting and when I find you I
guess sure
to haircut oh you guys go to the same
barber kickin acid every single scene of
this man truthfully that's that that was
my thing that I was like kind of
concerned about was is this movie gonna
go down the path that it was originally
marketed towards because I remember that
overall Jack Reacher's seem to have a
rather split decision when it came to
crowds a lot of people didn't like what
I remember the schmoes no hate it Jack
Reacher wise but Chris Stockman and
Jeremy Jones ripped like Chris Jeremy
John saw it was okay and Chris stuckman
thought it was great so this one I was
like okay well is this one going to
actually go down the path that the
original is marketed like or are they
going to try to do it again with a
really great like enhancing mysterious
story this could either be two things
the trailer is lying again or it's
exactly what it looks like it's gonna
because that looks like a lot of the
movie you know it looks like they showed
us a condensed version the movie as if
just the same this is the tone of the
first 20 minutes and this is the tone of
the next 20 minutes it's like every time
we got like 30 seconds further you know
25 seconds further it seemed like it was
getting a little bit bigger on the
Hollywood scale you start off is like
intriguing crime thriller that's also
like really heavy and cool and then it
ends in like full Michael Bay like yeah
I fully explosion witty lying he's
hooking a nap slitting already like
footing in disguise easy yeah he steals
a uniform he's Jack's a cop's car it's
like this movie is gonna progressively
get more and more extreme so it's gonna
start out feeling like the first movie
and it's gonna end feeling like you know
edge of tomorrow that's another thing
too I don't think that when it comes to
like these because the thing is like it
does look like a Tom Cruise flick again
yeah not what Jack Reacher looked like
that and it wasn't just that and I
remember people felt that way about edge
of tomorrow it looked like every recent
Tom Cruise film at the time
but it wasn't that so I can't say that
it's going to be exactly the same thing
what the trailer is giving us though so
maybe I feel I'd be on board for it
still like Tom Cruise kicking ass ain't
cool [ __ ] I'm fully on board for that I
love Tom Cruise I really love Tom Cruise
yeah I like watch interviews on YouTube
of Tom Cruise like I think he's a really
fun guy I don't I don't really watch his
like religious stuff
cobie smulders smolders to be kidnapped
I'm like ouch it's like I mean I am
running she got kidnapped Jack Reacher
was like what the [ __ ] the second he was
like I gotta take on the government yeah
it seems like there was a point in the
trailer where kind of started to lose me
where I got a little too big I don't
know I feel like that can either be
really cool and it'll just like somehow
become this kind of looks a lot more
straightforward or if it'll tip over and
just kind of give in to indulgence and
not work after a while because there is
a mystery and reveal vibe with the first
one this feels like it doesn't contain
any of that well in the first one I like
a Grimm all I want to know is yeah the
first one had like it was like a slow
burn kind of thriller in a lot of ways
do the action sequences look cool yeah
they do but there's also an edginess
that I feel is missing you miss from the
trailer for the first one I remember
thinking like this look that looks
violent like the money is like [ __ ]
up those guys at the bar well this like
this this looks like they were taking
action my scenes yeah well some of it
looks like action scenes but some of it
looks like they were trying to take
notes off of taken you know and stuff
like that you know make it the like cool
respected actor but he's also kicking
ass all the time movie and then it
becomes dire it's like the only thing we
don't really know is like who exactly
are these guys that Tom Cruise is going
after he's like I'm going to kill
everyone like that's all we got to find
out but I don't know I just I feel like
they'll tell us that pretty early movie
they like doing we'll watch it i watch
anything with Tom Cruise I'm gonna watch
I feel like this movie could just end up
being just like this trailer but a
little bit longer at the same time
though you know like I think audiences
might be ok with that because a lot of
people didn't lie I think I remember on
Rotten Tomatoes even and only have like
a 60% or something 63% I could see them
trying to make it better by like oh well
audiences really wanted was this so yeah
maybe they do a great job with it I'm
Tom Cruise kicks ass in films like that
no they make it look super fun and super
badass but they don't make like the
mystery I'm left with isn't enough to
make me like yeah I gotta see this you
know it just looks like an action movie
with a straightforward plot yeah I'm
like if this wasn't like Tom Cruise it
didn't look just badass enough I might
not be interested surely a creature
never go back not sure when that comes
out October perfect Halloween movie in
or near BG and although that you felt
like arrived to the real rejects just
won a whole video John I'm sorry but it
looked like Halloween that's I'm sure
Sean is the Jerry of the reasons and
he's a social media manager at bloom
house calm actually go to facebook.com
slash greenhouse way more interesting
and you can follow us on Instagram
Twitter and our Facebook is the real
region and I want to give a shout out to
Tom Cruise Tom you've been through a lot
lately with that whole fake divorce you
have with Katie Holmes and you have this
Asian looking baby amount even sure if
it's yours and people still speculate
that you might actually be a closeted
homosexual but despite all that I think
you were great and interview with a
vampire